un attentat ou accident l'explosion
d'une tonne d'artifice utilisés pour le
spectacle du puy du fou a créé une
certaine émotion l'autre nuit
une enquête est en cours l'hypothèse
d'un acte de malveillance n'est pas
exclu dix minutes avant l'explosion le
gardien de nuit avait effectué sa ronde
alors je suis parti environ à 1h30 du
matin pour être écoutés à une ronde de
doute le secteur quoi et je suis arrivé
ici je mets à peu près un quart d'heure
pour faire la ronde
bon je suis arrivé ici à la poudrière je
stationnais je suis descendu de la
voiture j'ai fait le tour avec ma pile
en donnant deux
d'éclairage sur votre truc j'ai vu aucun
indice qui pouvaient
[Musique]
lundi matin à 1h50
une violente explosion a détruit une
tante d'artifice utilisés pour les
nombreuses scènes du spectacle du puy du
fou en vendée des murs en béton
disloquées des blocs de plus d'une
centaine de kilos projeté à 30 50 voire
à 100 mètres de là il y avait dans ce
bâtiment dont il ne reste plus rien
hormis les fondations 30 millions de
centimes
accident ou acte de vandalisme l'anc est
immédiatement ouverte se poursuit des
expertises sont actuellement en pleine
recherche si je puis dire
les services compétents à la fois
départementaux les spécialistes nantais
est aujourd'hui même nous attendons les
spécialistes parisiens qui connaissent
bien sûr très bien la question sont en
train d'examiner le terrain pour
retrouver certains indices qui
pourraient expliquer le phénomène qui
s'est passé donc lundi soir je vous
rappelle que lors de mon arrivée j'étais
absolument stupéfait de voir l'ampleur
des dégâts et de retrouver sur tout ce
bois complètement en feu les spectacles
à venir
vont-ils être supprimés absolument pas
les spectacles à venir à commencer par
celui de vendredi soir se jouera comme à
l'habitude et avec des artifices nos
fournisseurs l'occasion fait des
miracles et arriveront à temps pour que
le spectacle se joue de la façon la plus
habituelle plus habituel qui soit
[Musique]